man you gotta give it up for this guy's
style you look at look at the sweater a
look at the sneakers look at the glass
this is him not trying
that's him not trying you just rolled
out of bed you look amazing
you look amazing yeah correct look at
you in that is that a trucker jacket I
think that's called a trucker that is a
trucker Jen they called the jungle I
think that's the trucker style well I
don't I don't think I look like a
trucker at all my apologies to all the
truckers that are watching you know we
don't wear that [ __ ] I'm I like this
jacket and I'm happy that you like it as
well thank you very much what that what
did you become a vampire okay take it
easy it's all gonna be good you know I
know
I saw him backstage but I didn't notice
until you walked out here that you're
wearing a Jeff Goldblum shirt yeah no I
noticed it and wasn't surprised and
that's why what what so you're it takes
a lot of nerve yeah we have a lot of
Conan merchandise I've never once worn
Conan O'Brien merchandise because it
seems like overload with this face but
you you are not afraid to do it I'm not
afraid of anything I don't know we made
a hip we made a hip shirt don't you
think so are you sucking on a candy
right now should I throw it off no no
it's fine but I've been doing this a
long time and interviewed thousand
people and you come on you like yeah
[Laughter]
it sounds good yeah that takes a lot of
you're so comfortable with yourself to
be sucking on a lozenge what I don't
sound like Edward who was that Randy
Robby Robinson sounding more and more
like him all the time yeah there's a lot
to talk about what are you playing with
your ring for oh that's what guys that
play with their wedding ring they have
to play say a lot of things about them I
do it a lot I take mine off all the time
I like it right well I mail it wasn't
say anything about us you know no I
don't think so but I like it it's so
cool I like mine Emily you know Mayday
Mayday Emily your wife my sweet sweet
wife yeah she made a sheet she had it
engraved
yeah headin great and it's very it's
pounded rose gold in there so it's very
so it's very uh he's that bag that's
nice isn't it yeah it's very nice I have
to tell you my story is that when I got
engaged to my wife and it was time for
pick out the wedding ring we went to the
store and the woman spent like two hours
talking to my wife about her ring this
is now 18 years ago and they're talking
to my wife and they're talking about the
ring and they're going in two hours and
then I said so what do I wear and she
went oh and she took out a coffee can
and turned it over I'm like 200 of these
is went clang
she went grab one there 100 bucks each
it's not fancy it's not yours is pounded
rose gold but you're it's a rose gold
krytus for a second I thought that was
just wedding ring yeah yeah
oh my god these are fantastic you're in
a fantastic man amazing man you're a
fantastic man thank you well this is
beautiful hey do you have something
written on it on anything yeah it says
off with this ring do it 18 years ago
years ago I knew this was coming up